la parole pour un rappel au règlement je
crois au président Hervé Marseille
oui monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la Première ministre
pardon je voudrais faire un rappel au
règlement en me fondant sur l'article 29
bis du du règlement
concernant une résolution que nous
avions déposé avec signé par plusieurs
présidents de groupe de cette assemblée
4 prés rillot le président maluré et le
président patria je voulais vous dire
que nous avons été étonnés de d'observer
que cette résolution n'avait pas été
inscrite à l'ordre du jour par le
gouvernement que nous n'avions pas été
prévenu en tous les cas moi j'ai pas été
prévenu en tant que signataire ce que
j'aurais aimé être et ce qui marque
quand même une certaine réserve
vis-à-vis du du Parlement j'ajoute que
cette résolution elle disait des choses
simples elle qualifiait les faits de ce
qui ve arriver en disant que le Hamas
éit un mouvement terroriste qui s'était
comporté de façon ignoble et que nous
demandions que ce qui pouvait être
qualifié de crime contre
l'humanité puisse faire l'objet d'une
instruction de la part de la France
devant la Cour de justice internationale
je pense que ce qu'on a fait pour les
boudhas de
Bamian en Afghanistan peut être fait
pour les populations massacrées en
Israël et donc
nous aurions en plus si je puis dire à à
la faveur de cette résolution avoir un
débat bien sûr mais aussi voter ce qui
ne sera pas le cas maintenant puisque
euh euh ce qui nous est proposé c'est un
débat au titre de l'article 50-1
c'est-à-dire que il va y avoir une
succession de de discours mais il n'y
aura pas de vote à la sortie donc on ne
sait pas ce que pensent les uns et les
autres donc voilà euh monsieur le
Président Madame la première ministre
messieurs les ministres que je voulais
dire en regrettant que nous n'ons pas pu
discuter de de cette résolution il y a
maintenant un débat au titre de
l'article 50-1 bien nous allons euh
débattre c'est mieux que rien mais je
regre vraiment que nous n'ai pas nous
n'ayons pas pu avoir cette discussion
dans le cadre de la résolution et que
nous n ayons pas pu voter c'est là le
principal objet de mon intervention
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
président
acte et donné de votre rappel au
règlement je vais maintenant donner la
parole à madame la Première ministre
Madame Élisabeth B madame la Première
ministre vous avez la
[Applaudissements]
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
ces dernières semaines ont été marquées
par un retour brutal et tragique de la
violence au proche-
Orient un retour aux conséquences
lourdes qui inquiète beaucoup de nos
concitoyens dans ce contexte vos
interrogations sont légitimes et
débattre de la situation était un
impératif démocratique je voudrais
peut-être insister sur le caractère
extrêmement évolutif de la situation et
c'est évidemment le cas avec le
déplacement en ce moment même du
président de la
République comme je l'ai fait hier à
l'Assemblée nationale je ne peux pas
m'exprimer devant vous sans commencer
par revenir sur les faits le 7 octobre
dernier une attaque terroriste barbare a
été menée par le Hamas et le Djihad
islamique contre l'État
d'Israël des crimes odieux ont été
commis des centaines de civils ont été
massacrés
des jeunes ont été sauvagement
assassinés lors d'une fête des actes
monstrueux ont été perpétrés dans des
kibuts comme à Berry karaza ou
REIM avec une brutalité sauvage des
femmes des hommes des personnes âgées
des enfants ont été enlevés ou
assassinés au total près de 1400
personnes ont été tuées dans les
attaques terroristes de ce mois
d'octobre et si quatre otages ont été
libérés plus de 200 personnes sont
encore
retenues parmi les victimes 30 de nos
compatriotes ont été tués et neuf sont
encore retenus en otage ou portés
disparu cette attaque n'était en rien
comparable aux épisodes de violence
comme comme il y en a malheureusement eu
d'autres dans l'histoire de cette région
ce déchaînement de barbarie commandité
et mis en œuvre par le Hamas montre un
changement de nature et
d'échelle il s'agissait d'une action
complexe et préméditée qui visit à
atteindre Israël et sa population en son
cœur avant de poursuivre mon propos je
tenais à rappeler ce
bilan tout comme le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de le faire
encore ce matin et comme je l'ai déjà
fait devant vous je veux dire une
nouvelle fois ma solidarité envers le
peuple israélien dans cette
épreuve je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour nos ressortissants
notamment pour les victimes françaises
et les disparus pour leurs proches leurs
famillees dès son arrivée en Israël ce
matin le président de la République a
rencontré individuellement les familles
des victimes et des disparus pour les
assurer de notre plein soutien et de
notre accompagnement dans le deuil et
l'inquiétude nous sommes à leur côté
nous partageons leur
peine mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
minimiser justifier voir absoudre le
terrorisme c'est acceptter qu'il frappe
à nouveau demain en Israël en France ou
partout
ailleurs nous ne devons faire preuve
d'aucune ambiguité face à de tels
crimes le président de la République l'a
encore affirmé avec force tout à l'heure
au côté du Premier ministre
israélien Israël a droit à la sécurité
Israël a le droit de se défendre dans le
respect du droit
international et ceux qui confondent le
droit du peuple palestinien à disposer
d'un état et la justification du
terrorisme commettent une faute morale
politique et
stratégique soyons très clair le Hamas
ne porte pas la cause
palestinienne aorité palestinienne est
notre interlocuteur légitime qui se bat
depuis des années pour la paix et a
besoin de notre
soutien le président de la République
s'entretient d'ailleurs en ce moment
même avec le président Mahmoud Abbas
aramala en agissant comme il l'a fait le
Hamas a exposé délibérément de manière
criminelle et cynique toute la
population de Gaza il utilise les
populations civiles comme bouclier
humain
il met en péril les espoirs de paix dont
le peuple palestinien a tant
besoin si je souhaitez commencer par
rappeler le bilan tragique des attaques
terroristes de ce mois
d'octobre si je m'apprête à évoquer les
milliers de victimes civiles de Gaza et
la situation humanitaire épouvantable
dans la zone c'est parce que nous ne
devons pas perdre de vue l'ampleur et la
gravité de la crise qui se joue il y a
des morts il y a des familles brisé
c'est une
tragédie je l'ai dit clairement hier il
n'y a pas de victime qu'il conviendrait
de pleurer moins que d'autres il n'y a
pas de vie qui Val moins que d'autres
nous sommes aussi au côté des familles
palestiniennes en
deuiller dans chacune de nos
interventions nous aurons l'occasion de
faire entendre nos sensibilités
politiques et nos différences mais face
à la gravité de la situation j'ai
confiance dans le Sénat pour débattre en
respons abilité avec la mesure et la
hauteur de vue qui caractérise cette
assemblée et que la situation
exige mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs depuis le 7 octobre le
président de la République a été en
contact très étroit avec les autorités
israéliennes il a porté un message clair
qu'il a encore répété tout à
l'heure Israël a évidemment le droit de
se défendre face au terrorisme les
civils doivent être épargnés
la réponse militaire doit se faire dans
le respect du droit international
notamment du droit international
humanitaire les populations ne doivent
pas payer pour les crimes des
terroristes notre pays ne connaî que
trop bien le lourd tribut des attentat
et nous devons l'affirmer avec force
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme il ne
s'agit jamais de se
renier si le terrorisme doit être
combattu la réponse des démocraties doit
être juste
même dans les combats les plus durs les
plus âpres nous ne devons jamais perdre
de vue ce qui fait de nous des
démocraties notre amitié et notre
solidarité avec le peuple israélien nous
nous oblige à formuler cet appel Israël
ne doit pas tomber dans le piège du
Hamas plusieurs milliers de Palestiniens
sont morts à Gaza dont plus de 2000
enfants des journalistes et plusieurs
dizaines d'employés des Nations Unies
ont été tués les 2 millions d'habitants
de Gaza sont dans une situation d'une
extrême gravité ces milliers de vies
fauchées nous touchent au
cœur mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
dans ce contexte le gouvernement est
mobilisé sur plusieurs front et nous
avons pris ces derniers jours les
mesures urgentes et immédiates qui
s'imposaient tout d'abord nous agissons
depuis la première heure pour la
sécurité de nos
ressortissants une cellule a immédiate
été activé au Centre de Crise du
ministère des Affaires étrangères les
services du quai d'orsé notamment notre
ambassade et notre consulat général à
telavive notre consulat général à
Jérusalem travaille jour et nuit pour
assurer un soutien aux familles de nos
compatriotes portés disparus ou tués
dans les
attaques bien sûr nous accordons une
attention particulière aux familles des
disparus je l'ai dit le président de la
République s'est entretenu avec elle ce
matin dès son arrivée en Israël
nous sommes en lien permanent avec ces
familles pour répondre à leurs
inquiétudes s'agissant des otages le
président de la République a rappelé
aujourd'hui que notre première priorité
était leur libération nous mettons tout
en œuvre pour l'obtenir au plus vite et
sans
conditions nous sommes par ailleurs en
lien avec la Communauté française sur
place pour lui apporter le soutien
nécessaire en 2 semaines la France a
permis à 00 de nos compatriotes de
rejoindre le territoire national depuis
Israël avec l'affritement de moyens
civils et le soutien de nos armées je
n'oublie pas les dizaines de Français
bloqués à Gaza dans des conditions
extrêmement précaires nous gardons un
contact très régulier avec eux nous
poursuivons nos efforts pour qu'ils
puissent quitter la
zone permettez-moi de rendre une
nouvelle fois hommage aux diplomates aux
militaires aux fonctionnaires français
engagés sans compter dans cette
situation très
éprouvante ensuite la France est
mobilisée pour venir en aide aux
population de
Gaza à Gaza nous devons regarder en face
l'ampleur de la catastrophe humanitaire
en cours plus d'un million de personnes
ont été déplacées l'accès au services
essentiel est quasiment interrompu la
nourriture et le FU manque les civils
n'ont plus d'eau les hôpitaux sont
saturés personne ne peut insensible face
à ce drame
humanitaire derrière l'ampleur des
bilans macabres il y a des femmes et des
hommes il y a des familles il n'y a pas
de nationalité d'origine ou de religion
qui vaille pour mesurer la gravité des
événements quand des civils meurent
chaque vie civile perdue est un échec
pour la communauté internationale les
populations Palestiniens ne peuvent être
abandonné à leur propre sort notre
solidarité avec elle ne saurait être
mise en en cause c'est pourquoi nous
demandons une trêve humanitaire qui
permette un accès sûr et immédiat pour
l'acheminement d'eau de nourriture de
foule et d'aide humanitaire et médicale
à Gaza cet accès doit se faire sous
l'égite des Nations Unis et la sécurité
des personnels humanitaires être
garantie même si plusieurs convois ont
désormais pu franchir la porte de Rafa
entre l'Égypte et la bande de Gaza c'est
encore
insuffisant nous appon à ce que la porte
de Rafa reste ouverte pour qu'une aide à
la hauteur de la situation puisse être
fournie aux populations
civiles comme l'a souligné la ministre
Catherine Colona au Ker ce weekend la
distribution d'aide exige une trêve
humanitaire qui pourra mener à un cesser
le feu nous demandons cette trêve au
plus
vite c'est un point important et je le
répète face au contre contevérité
diffusé notamment par la propagande
russe au Conseil de sécurité la France a
soutenu le projet de résolution présenté
par le Brésil dans cet objectif la
ministre des Affaires étrangères est
aujourd'hui à New York précisément pour
faire avancer les négociations au
Conseil de sécurité nous appelons à
mettre fin le plus vite possible à cette
période de
violence de plus comme le président de
la République l'a affirmé tout à l'heure
l'urgence est à rétablir l'électricité
dans les
hôpitaux la France a toujours soutenu
les populations civiles tinenne elle a
ainsi fourni près de 100 millions
d'euros d'aide pour les Palestiniens en
2022 cette aide est concentrée dans les
secteurs vitaux l'eau la santé
l'éducation
l'agriculture face à la situation
actuelle comme l'a annoncé le président
de la République nous avons décidé d'une
aide supplémentaire de 10 millions
d'euros et nous enverrons prochainement
un avion de fret humanitaire pour
soutenir la population de Gaza en outre
face à l'urgence l'Union européenne a
répondu prs prés an le montant de son
aide humanitaire à Gaza a été triplé et
deux vols ont permis d'acheminer plus de
50 50 tonnes d'aide à la
frontière le Conseil européen de cette
fin de semaine sera l'occasion de
revenir sur le sujet et de faire un
point sur le soutien que l'Europe peut
apporter puisque j'évoque l'aide que
nous apportons à la population
palestinienne de Gaza je voulais en
profiter pour revenir sur certaines
questions soulevées ces derniers jours
il est légitime de Sin RET et de veiller
à ce que notre aide humanitaire ne
puisse pas tomber entre de mauvaises
mains pour autant gardons-nous de
jugement hatif et définitif qui ne se
fonde que sur une vision biaisée des
faits comme je l'ai dit hier les
procédures mise en place pour éviter
tout détournement de notre aide par le
Hamas ou le Djihad islamique sont
stricts et scrupuleusement
respecté d'abord notre aide bilatérale
comme pour tous nos partenaires est
fourni avec l'accord de la communauté
internationale dont Israël selon des
procédures
agréées ensuite notre aide est mise en
œuvre par des agences de l'ONU et porte
sur des projets concrets comme je l'ai
évoqué enfin les aides sont contrôlé par
l'administration israélienne elle-même
c'est le cas pour nous comme pour nos
partenaires mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le troisième pilier de
l'action de la France c'est la
mobilisation pour éviter un embrasement
régional depuis la première heure le
président de la République la ministre
des Affaires étrangères et le ministre
des armées ont multiplié les échanges
avec leurs homologues de la région le
président de la République est
aujourd'hui en Israël où il a pu marquer
notre solidarité envers les familles et
faire entendre la voix singulière de la
France en faveur d'un processus
politique permettant d'éviter
l'escalade le président de la République
a été clair sur la responsabilité
attendue de certains acteurs de la
région afin d'éviter un embrasement
régional il a également proposé de bâtir
une coalition régionale et
internationale pour lutter contre les
groupes terroristes qui nous menacent
tous nous y travaillerons activement
avec nos partenaires
internationaux mais nous le savons la
lutte implacable contre le terrorisme ne
peut remplacer la recherche de la paix
la France plaide et plaidera pour un
règlement durable du conflit autour
d'une solution à deux états les
conditions sont claires des garanties
indispensable pour la sécurité d'Israël
et un état pour les
Palestiniens c'est la ligne que la
France défend avec constance et qu'elle
continuera à porter la sécurité durable
d'Israël la lutte résolue pour
l'éradication du terrorisme dans la
région et le respect des aspirations
légitimes de chacun forme un ensemble
semble
indissociable les États de la région ont
à ce titre une responsabilité
particulière la dynamique de
normalisation des relations entre Israël
et plusieurs des États de la région est
souhaitable elle doit s'accompagner
d'une d'une relance décisive du
processus politique pour répondre aux
aspirations légitimes des Palestiniens
et des
Israéliens notre responsabilité est
grande et nous l'assumons la France est
capable de parler à tout le monde le
président de la République sera
d'ailleurs ce soir à
Haman cette position indépendante nous
l'avons toujours assumé une position qui
nous donne un rôle pivot pour aider à
tracer le chemin de la paix mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la situation au
proche- Orient est complexe elle est
difficile elle conduit à des drames
épouvantables comme nous avons encore pu
le mesurer ces derniers jours
elle a des conséquences lourdes sur la
sécurité internation
elle trouve un écho particulier dans
chaque pays dans ce contexte la France a
une voix
singulière une voix issue d'une longue
histoire qui nous confère une
responsabilité une voix qui ne méconnaît
aucune des souffrances et défend
toujours l'exigence de justice et le
respect du droit humanitaire cette voix
la France continuera inlassablement à la
portée nous n'avons pas le droit de
renoncer la seule solution c'est la paix
je remerci
merci madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre dans la suite de notre débat la
parole est maintenant aux orateurs des
groupes monsieur le président Bruno
rotillot pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le président
première ministre messieurs les
ministres finalement c'est un débat ça
n'est pas une résolution c'est un débat
c'est un débat sans vote et je m'associe
au rappel au règlement que vient de
faire à l'entrée de la
séance mon collègue HERV Marseille la
différence entre une résolution et un
débat c'est le vote et cette résolution
est importante parce que le vote permet
à
chacun de s'engager et surtout la raison
d'être d'une assemblée du Parlement
c'est la
délibération nous allons donc débattre
entreetemps un professeur de français
est mort il était frappé par la
bêtimonde islamiste sur le sol de
France sur le sol sacré de l'école
républicaine et finalement cet événement
monstrueux parce que c'est un événement
monstrueux renforce encore plus cette
nécessité de voir notre assemblée
débattre et surtout s'exprimer sur ces
événements qui sont liés pourquoi parce
que d'une part je le disais tout est lié
et ce qui se passe là-bas nous concerne
ici en même temps et parce que notre
réponse ne peut pas souffrir ne peut pas
supporter la moindre ambigué la moindre
hésitation pourquoi est-ce que ce qui se
passe là-bas nous concerne pourquoi
est-ce que nous sommes directement
concernés nous sommes triplement je
crois nous sommes d'abord parce que nous
partageons avec le peuple juif juif mais
comme avec tous les peuples du
monde la même condition humaine
et ce qui est inhumain ne doit pas nous
être étranger comment ne pas être
horrifié par les images qui nous sont
arrivés comment ne pas être horrifié par
ces familles brûlé vives par ces femmes
enceintes et par ses enfants nouveau né
décapités
décapités symbole de l'innocence les
enfants parce que
juif comment ne pas être horrifié par
ces exactions qui constituent un crime
contre l'humanité oui her Marseille un
crime contre l'humanité et que comment
ne pas y voir dans cette violence
paroxistique comment ne pas y voir la
poursuite de l'entreprise génocidaire
par d'autres moyens rappelez-vous les
touts ont été massacrés à l'arme blanche
c'était à la machette donc nous sommes
concernés d'abord ce lien il est là dans
notre humanité
commune ce lien il est
aussi par cette
alliance par cette amitié par tous ces
liens qui sont irrévocables avec
Israël lien
historique forgé dans le
creuser de nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes des liens culturels
des liens civiques parce que nous
partageons avec Israël les valeurs
commune de la démocratie si rare au
proche-
Orient
et je voudrais simplement dire que c'est
au nom de cette amitié à la fois
spirituelle et et civique que les
terroristes nous visent veulent nous
détruire comme ils veulent détruire
Israël tout simplement parce que sur
l'échelle de la mécréance
nous sommes si j'ose dire au sommet nous
en raison de notre laïité et Israël
parce que c'est le peuple
juif et enfin nous sommes
liés nous sommes liés par le sang versé
par le sang français verset au momentù
je vous parle madame la Première
ministre 30 de nos compatriotes sont
morts 30 de nos compatriotes sont morts
et Dominique Bernard a été lâchement
assassiné le S français versé et les
images insoutenables qu'on a pu
découvrir nous rappellent d'autres
images qui nous hantent encore celle des
images des attentats et plus qu'aucun
autre peuple sur la planète je pense que
le peuple français se doit de se tenir
au côté du peuple juif parce que nous
avons connu la même morsure la même
morsure sanglante du
terrorisme du totalitarisme
islamiste alors que faire désormais que
faire d'abord bien sûr nous tenir au
côté
d'Israël je voudrais simplement rappeler
un point qui me paraît fondamental et
vous l'avez abordé madame la Première
ministre dans votre
intervention ce qui s'est passé cette
violence inouï ça n'est pas l'expression
désespérée d'une cause de la cause
palestinienne c'est la résurgence du
totalitarisme islamiste que ce soit bien
clair le Hamas bien sûr ne porte pas la
cause palestinienne il il
l'instrumentalise ilinstrumentalise il
la défigure il la défigure en
l'islamisant en la talibanisant en la
déshumanisant et je voudrais simplement
rappeler à tous les Islam gauchiste qui
se déshonore en refusant de qualifier en
refusant de qualifier de
terroriste les crimes qui ont été commis
je voudrais simplement faire quelques
rappels
le Hamas c'est pas un mouvement de
libération c'est un acronyme qui
signifie d'ailleurs mouvement de
résistance islamique l'inspirateur qui
n'est plus le le CH Yassine son crédau
ça n'est pas de libérer la Palestine son
crédau c'était de soumettre la Palestine
à la charia à la loi islamiste il y a
des écrits il y a des dires les choses
doivent être claires et tous les efforts
du Hamas depuis des années a consisté
très clairement à saboter tous les
efforts de paix y compris les accords
d'Oslo et aujourd'hui ce qu'il s'agit de
faire à travers ce crime contre
l'humanité c'est évidemment empêcher
toute réconciliation et notamment entre
Riyad était la vive sans doute au
bénéfice de l'Iran et l'Iran
vraisemblablement personne ne le dit je
le dis et vraisemblablement derrière
cette opération par différents
moyens les choses de ce point de vue-là
doivent être très très clair mais nous
devons pour ce qui nous concerne être
très ferme très ferme pour dire que il
faut tirer tous les enseignements un en
matière d'antisémitisme la tolérance et
la tolérance zéro même quand
l'antisémitisme avance masqué derrière
l'antisionisme je voudrais simplement
rappeler une formule oubliée de Jean
kellevic grand philosophe Jean kelevic
qui disait que l'antisionisme en réalité
c'estit bien pratique par parce que il
permettait
l'antisémitisme sans le racisme c'est
exactement cela ce que je vous demande
madame la Première ministre c'est une
tolérance zéro vis-à-vis de ces
nouvelles formes d'antisémitisme parce
que l'antisémitisme en France a
muuté dans ses ressorts aussi bien
politiques y compris dans ses ressorts
religieux il faut absolument en en tenir
compte deuxième élément là encore vous
l'avez indiqué pas un €o ne doit aller à
une organisation de type terroriste
comme le Anas pas 1 € bien sûr que on
peut pas retenir les fonds humanitaires
mais on doit par un travail de contrôle
extrêmement rigoureux tout vérifier chez
nous nos aides mais aussi les aides
européennes qui constituent un paquet
important c'est absolument fondamental
et je voudrais simplement aussi pour
terminer dire que on peut parfaitement
être au côté
d'Israël reconnaître à Israël le droit
de se défendre en rappelant
évidemment que toute victime civile est
toujours un drame bien sûr que la PR la
vie des uns vaut la vie des autres
riposter éradiquer de hamass dans le
cadre du droit international parce que
l'honneur des démocraties ça n'est
jamais de de s'abaisser aux valeurs de
ceux qui justement voudrai nous tirer
vers le bas bien sûr donc se tenir au
côté d'Israël fermement de façon
déterminée j'ai écouté moi aussi les
propos du président de la République à
quelques heures ça signifie évidemment
le reconnaître le droit de se défendre
d'éradiquer le Hamas d'éradiquer le
Hamas mais c'est aussi leur tenir un
langage de vérité ce langage de vérité
c'est de dire que depuis 30 ans depuis
30 ans aucune guerre n'a été gagnée sans
solution
politique les Américains l'ont l'ont
appris en
Afghanistan en Irak nous l'avons appris
nous les français en Afrique au
Sahel il faut le redire bien sûr qu'il
faut éradiquer le Hamas mais une
solution politique devra être trouvé une
espérance vis-à-vis aussi du peuple
palestinien devra se lever cette
espérance nous l'avons toujours proclamé
c'est la ligne française de la
diplomatie française c'est aussi la
ligne du Sénat ça a toujours été la
solution à deux états alors évidemment
prononcer aujourd'hui à cette tribune
cette perspective qui nous paraît
terriblement éloigné paraître totalement
illusoire utopique mais il faut le
rappeler on le voit bien que après
toutes ces années d'un conflit qui était
en quelque sorte gelé que aujourd'hui la
violence est
revenue mais encore une une fois Israël
a le droit de se défendre et il faut
minimiser bien sûr au maximum les
victimes civiles mais c'est le Hamas qui
a déclenché les hostilités et c'est le
Hamas qui abolit toute distinction entre
les civiles et les militaires en prenant
les civils comme des boucliers il faut
rappeler cette évidence et en même temps
déployer tous nos efforts diplomatiques
à l'avenir dans les mois prochains pour
que la France puisse promouvoir et nous
avons un rôle une responsabilité
particulière que vous avez rappelé
madame la Première ministre cette
solution à deux états pour conclure ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que ce combat
c'est à nouveau le combat sans cesse
recommencé contre le terrorisme
islamiste bien sûr au moment où je vous
parle le totalitarisme islamiste ne
s'est jamais aussi bien porté dans le
monde
jamais malgré les interventions
occidentales il règne à Kabul
il revient en Irak il s'étend il se
répand en Afrique au Sahel et il frappe
en France bien sûr qu'il faut être
intraitable et la réponse et notre
réponse aussi au terrorisme doit être
une réponse judiciaire
policière législative
peut-être mais ça doit être une réponse
totale une réponse globale ce que je
veux dire c'est que et ça peut paraître
très paradoxal
mais en nous désignant comme leurs
ennemis les terroristes islamistes en
nous
désignant en ciblant
l'école la
laïcité il nous montre un chemin de
résistance il nous montre la voix par
laquelle on peut répondre cette réponse
on le voit bien c'est l'idéal
républicain par exemple de la la cité
c'est cette école qui le creusit par
laquelle on transmet pas seulement des
connaissances des compétences
individuelles mais on transmet une
grandamère collective qui permettra
demain des citoyens d'intégrer
pleinement le destin national l'école
c'est ce creuser d'un idéal français
avec l'idéal républicain mais pour leur
madame la Première ministre messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues pour
leur réaffirm solennellement
solennellement n'oublions pas les
victimes je trouve qu'on passe trop vite
par perte et profits est victime en
Israël n'oublions pas et réaffirmons
solennellement ici au Sénat dans notre
haute assemblée le soutien indéfectible
notre solidarité solidarité française à
la nation israélienne au peuple juif
parce que aujourd'hui il porte le
flambeau de la démocratie au prix du
sang dans cette région du Proche Orient
merci de votre attention
merci merci monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant au président
canner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain parle monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la premierre ministre messieurs les
ministres permettez-moi de ses propos
par une
citation la violence il faut la dénoncer
il faut la vomir il faut l'isoler ce
n'est pas la voix des
démocraties ces mots sont ceux prononcé
par le premier ministre yitrak Rabin le
4 novembre
1995 lors du grand meeting pour la paix
place des roi d'Israël à telavive ces
mots raisonnent en nous dans cette
terrible actualité
quelques minutes plus tard kit
frakraabin était
assassiné les heures sombres de
l'obscurantisme sont de retour les actes
terroristes qui ont été perpétrés le 7
octobre dernier doivent nous révolter et
je vous invite à écouter les mots du
colonel Weissberg en charge de
l'opération d'identification des
victimes je m'excuse tout de suite pour
la dureté de la description que je vais
vous faire je
cite que dire lorsque vous découvrez le
corps d'une femme enceinte tuée par un
terroriste qui lui a ouvert le ventre
puis en a extrait le fétus avant de leur
couper la tête à tous les deux et que
dire encore face au corps des mères ou
de grand-mères qui ont été violé
sauvagement mes chers collègues le
massacre de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
dans les kibousim du sud d'Israël doit
nous révolter de la même manière des
enfants qui meurent sous les
bombardements des civils privés d'eau
d'électricité de nourriture toute une
population prise en en étau doit nous
révolter de telles atrocités doivent
être nommé dénoncé ne pas le faire
serait insupportable et inexcusable même
même si nous avons identifié le fait
générateur celui d'une organisation
terroriste qui depuis 2007 pratique la
tyrannie compris contre le peuple
qu'elle est censé représenter Israël a
le droit et le devoir absolu d'éliminer
cette émanation sanguinaire de l'IDRE
islamiste qui est le
Hamas j'ai entendu ce matin les mots du
président de la République madame la
Première ministre visant à créer une
coalition internationale à l'instar de
celle qui existe contre daesh madame la
Première ministre nous avons besoin de
précision sur cette annonce son
périmètre exact et sur son
opérationnalité les actes qui ont été
commis par le Hamas sont souvent
qualifiés d'indicible mais pour moi il
doivent être nommé de manière très
claire ces monstruosités constituent les
pires horreurs que le monde est connu
depuis les années 1990 durant lesquels
eurent lieu le génocide randais ou le
massacre de
seranita ici c'est l'acte génocidaire le
plus important contre le peuple juif
depuis la choix et le temps des pogromes
et les milliers de civils palestiniens
Mor en des représailles israéliennes
contre le Hamas sont aussi
insupportables toute vie sacrifiée est
un drame pour l'humanité tout crime
contre l'humanité mérite une réponse
mais la silération ne doit pas nous
paralyser mes chers collègues au
contraire nous devons nous élev et
constituer de véritables remparts contre
les forces obscurantistes car le Hamas
n'est pas une représentation politique
c'est une organisation terroriste qui
vise l'islamisation totale en détruisant
notre modèle de société il cherche non
pas exterminer l'État d'Israël mais
exterminer tout juif comme toute
personne qui n'accepterait pas de se
soumettre à sa loi pour vous convaincre
lisez ou relisez les 36 articles de la
Charte du
Hamas aucune solution politique n'est
envisageable avec une telle organisation
qui refuse toute forme de négociation
diplomatique après les attentat de Paris
ou de Nice notre lutte contre DAEs
comporte bien des similitudes avec la
situation présente
et pourtant pour les civils pour les
otages il faut avoir du courage avec
pour seul mot d'ordre pacifier protéger
obtenir un cesser le feu humanitaire ou
à défaut assurer un couloir humanitaire
solide nous supposons que c'est l'objet
du déplacement du président de la
République même si nous aurions préféré
madame la Première ministre que cette
nécessaire visite puisse se dérouler
après la fin du débat au Parlement
croyant à la parole de la France nous
espérons ne pas être déçu par les
résultats effectifs de cette visite le
Hamas nous replonge dans l'horreur et
dans toute la noirceur de la guerre
ravivant la mémoire des pires épisodes
de notre histoire comme daesh le
Hezbollah le dihad islamique al-qïda ou
bokoaram le Hamas est l'un des bras
armés d'une conquête internationale au
profit d'un régime totalitaire c'est la
résurgence cela a été dit par mon
collègue grotillot du mouvement
islamiste qui parvient à se réinventer
chaque jour avec les S que sont le Qatar
ou l'Iran Israël ne nous trompons pas
queles que soient nos réserves sur les
moyens militaires utilisés représente
actuellement le premier bouclier contre
ce projet politique liberticide et vient
d'être à nouveau malheureusement la
première victime de ce projet en ce
moment j'ai une pensée pour nos
compatriotes le bilan est terrible les
victimes françaises
aujourd'hui recensés sont au nombre de
30 au moins et de neuf disparus et otage
présumé jamais autant de Français n'ont
été victimes du terrorisme depuis les
terribles attentats de Nice en
2016 pour autant ne faisons pas
d'amalgame mes chers collègues dans
notre pays les partisans de la création
d'un État islamique ne sont qu'une
extrême minorité et pourtant chaque acte
terroriste est un traumatisme à juste
titre national je tiens à le rappeler à
le souligner dans cette période où les
tensions communautaires sont ex Serb le
conflit en cours au Proche Orient ne
doit pas s'importer sur notre territoire
comme un conflit entre religions notre
responsabilité en tant que politique est
de veiller à ce qu'aucune discrimination
aucun amalgame ne soit admis pas
d'amalgame mais pas d'angélisme non plus
la tolérance zéro doit s'appliquer face
à
l'antisémitisme comme face à toute
discrimination à l'encontre de nos
compatriotes de confession musulmanes le
principe de de laïcité notre principe de
laïcité qui est au cœur de notre
République impose le respect et la
protection de
l'attachement et l'attachement des
croyants à la Bible au cro au Coran ou à
la Torah mais aucun des préceptes de ces
livres sacrés pour ces croyants ne
peuvent être considérés comme supérieur
à la loi de la République arestide
brillant résuma cela en proclamant et
vous le dites souvent monsieur le
Président la loi protège la foi tant que
la foi ne dicte pas sa loi
transiger avec ces principes c'est
affaiblir durablement notre pacte
républicain transiger avec ces principes
c'est faire mourir une deuxième fois
Samuel paatti et Dominique Bernard
l'assassinat de ce dernier il y a 11
jours à haras moins d'une semaine après
les attaques du Hamas témoignent des
risques qui pèsent dans notre pays cet
attentat doit nous alerter sur l'absence
de risque zéro face à la menace
terroriste mais nous oblige également
sur notre devoir de mettre en place des
mesures de protection et de prévention
la sanction est nécessaire mais quels
sont nos moyens de lutter contre la
radicalisation notamment chez les jeunes
exclure des élèves de nos établissements
scolaires pour comportement
inacceptaable lors de la minute de
silence à la mémoire de Dominique
Bernard bien sûr mais j'ai envie de dire
et
après la prévention du poison
totalitaire qui infecte des cerveaux
perméables à cette idéologie mortifère
doit être au cœur de notre action
républicaine mes chers collègues s'il
existe des proies dans nos villes et nos
quartiers c'est qu'il existe aussi des
prédateurs et n'oublions jamais que 75 %
des attentats islamistes commis sur
notre territoire l'ont été par des
Français notre République ne peut
s'accommoder de devoir protéger des
compatriotes du fait même de leur
religion érigé en identité le faire bien
évidemment pour pour des raisons
évidentes de sécurité c'est néanmoins
reconnaître en creux que notre pacte
républicain et notre principe du vivre
ensemble sont menacé voire
nié c'est la même chose lorsqu'on
s'attaque à l'un de nos compatriotes
parce qu'il est professeur et qu'il
représente notre institution nationale
porteuse d'émancipation et en charge
d'éclairer de forger les esprits
critiques les semeurs de terreur ont
horreur de nos lumières de la démocratie
de la laïcité de la liberté d'expression
ou encore du droit absolu des femmes à
disposer de leur corps j'en reviens pour
terminer à la situation du conflit
israélo-palestinien depuis 30 ans la
solution à deux états n'est toujours pas
mise en œuvre depuis 95 et l'assassinat
d'itraak Rabin par un ultra nationaliste
israélien l'esprit des accords d'Oslo
n'est qu'un vague souvenir qui se
dissipe progressivement dans les vapeurs
de l'escalade des violences la la
politique actuelle du gouvernement
israélien n'est pas exemple de critique
la tendance actuelle est effectivement
inquiétante et répond à une réelle
radicalisation politique à vocation
ultra nationaliste il nous faut
condamner avec fermeté les choix opérés
depuis de trop nombreuses années qui
mettent en péril toute résolution du
conflit ces choix contribuent à
exacerber les tensions empêchent toute
perspective pour la jeunesse
palestinienne privée de tout espoir
d'émancipation les réactions désespérées
de cette jeunesse que je condamne
conforte ensuite l'extrême droite
israélienne dans sa politique d'annexion
l'engrenage est sans fin ce cercle
vicieux condamne tout avancé sur le
chemin de la paix et j'étais horrifié il
y a quelques jours d'entendre sur une
chaîne de radio les mots d'un père
vivant dans un village dirigé par le
Hezbollah dans le Sud Liban ce père
venait de perdre son fils lors d'une une
incursion en Israël et il disait la
Palestine a besoin du sang de ses
martyres des mots qui font peur mais qui
nous oblige à agir en tant que
socialiste nous soutenons la
reconnaissance de deux États souverains
c'est le seul chemin que nous devons
emprunter collectivement les
progressistes Palestiniens comme la
gauche israélienne qui reste puissante
doivent œuvrer dans le sens d'une
résolution durable de ce conflit et il
est de notre rôle de soutenir toute
initiative de leur part nous devons
relayer ces démarches positives appelant
à combattre la surenchè favorisant le
dialogue et apaisant les tensions
intercommunautaires et je pense aux
guerrières de la paix à ce mouvement
woman wage peace et à tous ces
organismes qui proposent de tisser des
liens et de créer des ponts plutôt que
des murs entre les deux côtés ces
militants de la paix sont souvent
combattus férocement par les forces
extrémistes des deux camps cela témoigne
de la pertinence de leur combat chers
collègues oui il faut favoriser une
reprise du dialogue pour cela du côté
palestinien une véritable force
démocratique et une construction
politique tournant le dos notamment à la
à la corruption sont nécessaires ne pas
l'encourager ne pas la favoriser
reviendra de fait à fragiliser la
démocratie israélienne sans ses
prèrequis aucune négociation n'est
possible pour terminer la France et
l'Europe doivent insuffler une dynamique
nous devons collectivement tout mettre
en œuvre pour installer un climat de
désescalade le rapport sénatorial de
décembre 2022 porté par la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées armées du Sénat et son
président de l'époque que je salue
Christian Cambon était très ins IR an
tant dans son diagnostic que dans la
perspective et dans les recommandations
après s'être rendu sur place le but des
auteurs du rapport était de s'interroger
sur les chances de reprise d'un dialogue
autour de la solution à deux états les
conditions d'une nouvelle feuille de
route avaient été clairement définies
dans ce rapport il faut les relire il
faut nous les approprier monsieur le
Président je termine je vous assure en
attendant un retour sur le chemin de la
raison ce sont les peuples d'Israël et
de Palestine qui sont pris en otage une
prise d'otage idéologique aux
conséquences mort
ce sont les enfants de ces deux peuples
qui subissent les foudres de la violence
qui seront marqués dans leur chair au
fer rouge de la guerre et pourtant mes
chers collègues ce sont les enfants de
ces deux peuples qui ont la lourde
charge de mettre un terme à cette guerre
sans fin les solutions existent ell
reposent sur l'esprit de raison le
respect mutuel et la foi inébranlable en
un avenir de paix Shalom
salam merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au
président non la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Olivier kadiic pour le groupe
de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues plus de de semaines après les
attaques meurtrières du Hamas sur le
territoire israélien qui ont fait plus
de 1400 morts nous sommes toujours
profondément
choqués je tiens avant tout au nom du
groupe Union centriste avoir une pensée
pour toutes les victimes innocentes
parmi elles nous uron 30 compatriotes
tués nous comptons toujours également
neu français portés disparus dont une
jeune femme qui a le statut d'otage nous
soutenons les efforts du gouvernement
pour obtenir en priorité la libération
de tous les otages notre groupe exprime
sa compassion aux blessés aux familles
des victimes aux proches des otages
enlevés qui vivent dans l'angoisse nous
pensons aussi à toutes les victimes
civiles qu'ell soi soit en Israël et à
Gaza et à tous ceux qui sont désormais
dans la
souffrance nous imaginions avoir comm
connu des sommets de monstruosités avec
les attentats d'Al-Qaïda du 11 septembre
ou ceux de daesh le 13 novembre 2015 à
Paris avec les exactions du 7 octobre
dernier en Israël le Hamas
s'inscrit dans cette barbare compétition
des organisations terroristes islamistes
il a enchaîné massacre de masse acte de
torture d'une cruauté bestiale mais
aussi enlèvement de plus de 200 civils
aujourd'hui séquestrés les mots
demeurent impuissants face à
l'ignominiie nous condamnons cette
organisation terroriste et ses actes
avec force Israël est en droit de se
défendre et de chercher à éliminer le
Hamas qui a pour objectif lui-même de
faire disparaître l'État hébreux de la
carte dans un premier temps car ne nous
y trompons pas le Hamas tout comme daesh
ou Al-Qaïda vivent dans la haine de nos
valeurs et vivent visent la destruction
à terme de la civilisation occidentale
les attentats d'aras et Bruxelles qui
ont suivi nous l'ont douloureusement
rappelé on comprend dès lors pourquoi le
président de la République a pu proposer
aujourd'hui à Jérusalem que la coalition
internationale actuellement déployé en
Irak et en Syrie pour lutter contre
l'État islamique puisse aussi lutter
contre le Hamas la population
palestinienne de Gaza est aussi l'otage
de cette organisation terroriste qui
mène ses attaques militaires depuis des
installations civiles rien ne serait
pire que de vouloir confondre le Hamas
avec la cause palestinienne et sa
légitime revendication à disposer d'un
État autonome le Hamas a franchi une
ligne rouge pour qu'Israël ne puisse
plus accepter le moindre accord dès lors
quelle solution adopter pour Israël à
Gaza déplacer le Hamas au Qatar ou les
Palestiniens vers l'Égypte ou la
Jordanie impossible aucun État ne
l'accepterait faire une barrière avec
une démarcation large de plusieurs
kilomètres éminé à l'image de la
démarcation entre les deux Corées ce
serait condamneré la population de Gaza
à la misère et à laisser la haine
grandir en attendant la prochaine
érruption bombarder la BAMBE de gaz de
Gaza indistinctement en exposant toute
la population palestinienne c'est le
piège tendu par le Hamas qui veut
réussir là où daesh a échoué et nous
souhaitons que la démocratie israélienne
combattent en respectant le droit
international humanitaire mais tout le
monde voit bien la difficulté car les
terroristes se cache dans la population
elle-même une difficulté supplémentaire
pour le gouvernement israélien vient de
ce que l'organisation terroriste a le
soutien de l'Iran la déclaration récente
du ministre des Affaires étrangères
iranien appelant à éradiquer les Juifs
et à rayer Israël de la carte en est une
nouvelle illustration elle vient
rejoindre en tout point la doctrine du
Hamas la Russie jubile la Chine est le
banquier de
l'attelage vous remarquerez que pour ces
trois états Iran Russie ou Chine le
Hamas n'est pas une organisation
terroriste
la situation est très préoccupante si
Israël bombarde Gaza et élimine
effectivement le Hamas qui gérera Gaza
en ruine que deviendra alors ce qui sera
un immense bidonville comment éviter que
toute la jeunesse palestinienne ne tombe
à son tour dans le panneau des sirènes
du Hamas avec l'effondrement de
l'Autorité palestinienne en S Jordanie
comment ne pas craindre l'escalade
régionale avec le hzbollah proxy de
l'Iran qui non content d'étrangler le
Liban est susceptible de plonger le pays
du Cèdre à nouveau dans un conflit avec
son
voisin hier j'assistais à la prise
d'armes aux Invalides présidé par le
ministre des Armées Sébastien le Cornu à
l'occasion des 40 ans de l'attentat du
dracar à Beyrouth où 58 militaires
français ont perd ont perdu la vie ne
les oublions pas 700 militaires français
sont déployés dans le cadre de la force
intérimaire des Nations unis au Liban la
frontière avec Israël il serait alors en
première ligne d'une reprise des
hostilités ne l'oublions pas le rapport
du président Cambon et de la commission
des affaires étrangères intitulé Israël
Palestine redonner un horizon politique
au processus de paix avait anticipé il y
a un peu moins d'un an l'embrasement que
nous déplorons
aujourd'hui la formation du gouvernement
de monsieur netanahou qui aie la droite
avec une extrême droite composée de
suprémacistes Juifs tenant d'une
idéologie expansionniste et visant un
État théocratique soumis à la loi
religieuse menace les fondements de la
démocratie israélienne il pose un
problème de morale et de conscience que
les manifestations hebdomadaires dans
l'État hébreux ont révélé de nombreux
articles de presse ont sonné l'alarme
dans une tribune du Monde du 9 février
sophie Bessis écrivait suite à la
sanglante attaque d'une synagogue de
semaines plus tôt d'un côté les
provocations délibérées de ministres
israéliens pressé de montrer aux
Palestiniens de quel côté ce situe la
force de l'autre la monté d'un désespoir
mortifère devant la dégradation des
conditions de vie en sis-jordanie et
l'absence de toute perspective de paix
dans la justice ont conduit à
l'explosion actuelle si rien n'est fait
elle risque de prendre des proportions
que nul ne parviendra à contenir fin de
citation une de haine n'a jamais donné
un bon résultat pour les peuples il est
majeur de se consacrer dès maintenant à
la paix l'escalade de violence en
territoire israëlo-palestinien vient
nous rappeler que la solution à deux
états un État d'Israël et un État
palestinien est la seule solution viable
pour la paix je me réjouis que le
Président de la République soit
aujourd'hui à Tel Aviv pour reprendre
l'initiative politique et réaffirmer une
exigence que le général de gale éfoquait
déjà de façon visionnaire lors de sa
conférence de presse du 27 novembre 1967
mais il est vrai que les accords
d'Abraham ont permis des avancées
majeures auprès des pays du Golf ils ont
apporté une nouvelle dynamique de
normalisation
israello-arabe comme président du groupe
d'amitié France pays du Golf je n'ai pu
que m'en féliciter ces avancées très
concrètes se sont traduites par de
réelles coopérations sécuritaires et
militaires comme j'avais pu le souligner
en mai 2022 lors d'un colloque que j'ai
accueilli au Sénat en compagnie du
président Roger caruchci mais si les
accords d'Abraham ont vocation à
promouvoir la paix aux frontières
d'Israël tous mes interlocuteurs du golf
m'ont toujours affirmé que la résolution
du conflit israëlo-palestinien restait
une priorité pour emporter l'adhésion de
leur population en ne s'alignant pas sur
les États-Unis en 2003 dans son
intervention en Irak la France a prouvé
son indépendance au Moyen-Orient la
France est un tiers de confiance
naturelle pour amorcer un nouveau
dialogue et un nouveau n horizon au
processus de paix notre pays a soutenu
sans discontinuer le droit d'Israël à
exister et à vivre du en sécurité d'une
part la création d'un État palestinien
vivant dans des frontières sûres est
reconnu d'autre part il est vital pour
tous d'abandonner la stratégie de la
cécité volontaire et du dénis de réalité
à l'égard de la réalité palestinienne
pour Israël cela consistera à abandonner
sa stratégie de colonisation en
Cisjordanie et à Jérusalem Est pour la
Palestine cela signifie la la fixation
d'un calendrier démocratique avec des
garanties de déroulement des scrutins en
sis-jordanie Gaza Jérusalem est la
France doit être l'aiguillon afin que
l'Europe mette en place un nouveau
dialogue entre Israël et Palestine
l'Union a débloqué 200 millions d'euros
d'aide aux Palestiniens avant le conflit
elle doit maintenant investir le volet
politique en plus du volet humanitaire
je salue le rôle de l'Égypte qui a
autorisé le passage d'une aide
humanitaire vers Gaza après de longues
journées de de fermeture du
poste-frontière il faut en effet porter
secours aux civil Gazaoui qui manque de
produits de première nécessité la
décision d'une aide supplémentaire de 10
millions d'euros portés par la France
mérite d'être souligné vendredi un vol
spécial qu' voira du fret médical une
fois de plus la France répond présente
et les sénateurs centristes soutiennent
cette initiative être en empathie avec
les personnes qui souffrent et provoquer
la désescalade par la promotion de la
paix pour apporter l'espoir d'une vie
dans la sécurité et et la sérénité au
proch ariant telle est la démarche
d'apaisement qui je l'espère sera portée
avec succès par le président la
République je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole ma cher
collègu merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres M chers collègues nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour évoquer
la situation grave et les tragédies qui
se déroulent actuellement au Proche
Orient région qui est le théâtre de
défis de tension et de conflits
persistants depuis près de 75 ans par sa
résolution 181 du 29 novembre 1947
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
adopte le plan de partage de la
Palestine posant le principe de la
création de deux États souverains et
indépendants en
1948 l'État d'Israël a été créé et le
conflit israélo-palestinien est né il y
a eu des guerres
israello-arabes puis la guerre du Kipour
il y a eu ensuite une première Intifada
en
1987 les accords d'Oslo de
1993 appelant à une solution à deux
états sont venus apporter un vent
d'espoir malheureus
il s'agit d'un processus
inachevé depuis l'histoire du conflit se
poursuit elle est rythmée par de
multiples épisodes de tension plus ou
moins aigu et plus ou moins longs le
dernier en dat est survenu il y a TR
semaines quand les terroristes du Hamas
et du Djihad islamique ont attaqué le
peuple israélien il s'agit d'une
séquence nouvelle dans un conflit qui ne
s'est jamais éteint pour reprendre les
mots du politologue Bertrand Badi mais
ces événements sont inédits par la
nature de leur violence depuis plusieurs
semaines nous sommes les témoins de
nouvelles images d'une barbarie sans
précédent nous sommes nombreux à
exprimer notre colère notre notre
bouleversement face à la tragédie qui se
déroule sous nos yeux les adjectifs ne
sont pas assez forts pour dénoncer ces
atrocités le groupe RDP soutient le
peuple israélien condamne sans détour et
avec la plus grande fermeté ces ces
attaques terroristes nous le
martellerons jamais assez rien ne
justifie le terrorisme nulle part ni
jamais cela est une évidence sauf pour
certains pourtant notre pays a été
frappé de nombreuses fois par le
terrorisme et
l'obscurantisme cela a encore été le cas
récemment avec l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard à
haras la présence du président de la
République en Israël aujourd'hui est un
témoignage du soutien entier et sincère
que la France porte à l'égard d'Israël
il prend racine dans l'amitié profonde
et ancienne qui lit notre nation au
peuple israélien nous avons également
une pensée pour le peuple palestinien
pris en étau entre les terroristes du
Hamas et l'armée israélienne vous avez
raison Madame la première ministre les
Palestiniens ne sont pas le Hamas et le
Hamas n'est pas le peuple palestinien en
juin 2022 je me suis rendu en Israël à
Gaza et en sixisjordanie avec des
collègues sénateurs de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées sous la présidence de
Christian Cambon que je salue cette
mission avait pour thème l'avenir du du
processus de paix au Proche Orient nous
avions ressenti alors une très forte
tension à Gaza et à Hébron et perçu le
danger que représentait l'absence de de
perspective dans notre rapport de 12
recommandations la délégation avait
estimé que la solution à deux états
restait la seule voix acceptable et
crédible à condition de redonner un
horizon politique et un agenda au
processus de paix la seule à même de
répondre aux aspirations légitimes des
Israéliens et des Palestiniens à la
sécurité l'indépendance et à la
reconnaissance à la dignité
malheureusement un ans après la
situation s'est dégradée de plus en plus
et a fini par s'embraser et cela nous
l'avions ressenti aujourd'hui le Hamas
et le Djihad islamique anéantissent les
espoirs et les aspirations légitimes de
ces deux peuple à vivre en paix les
terroristes balaient tous les efforts
menés pour une pour bâtir une paix
durable et il le sèent que la désolation
et la mort le Hamas doit être éradiqué
le terroristme n'a pas n'a pas de
frontières notre pays se retrouve une
nouvelle fois endeuillé le bilan est
lourd pour nos compatriotes nous
retenons notre souffle en espérant que
les Français portés disparu soient
retrouvés sains et SAU et sauve depuis
Israël notre président de la République
adresse un message fort aux Français
victime de ce conflit ainsi qu'à leur
famill depuis 3 semaines la population
civile retenue dans les zones de conflit
est en proie à de nombreux périls
dangers mortel de la guerre manque de
nourriture et de médicaments il faut
éviter une nouvelle dégradation de la
situation humanitaire madame la Première
ministre comme vous l'avez rappelé hier
à l'Assemblée nationale la porte de Rafa
doit être ouverte quotidiennement et en
permanence pour permettre aux habitants
de la bande de Gaza de recevoir l'aide
humanitaire internationale celle-ci doit
être renforcée à l'exemple de la France
qui augmente de 10 millions d'euros
l'aide destinée au
Gazaoui nous ne sommes pas en train
d'assister à une guerre conventionnel il
ne s'agit pas d'un conflit opposant deux
armées régulières Israël a le droit de
se défendre contre ces attaques
terroristes toutefois s ripost ne peut
se faire en contradiction avec ses
obligations de respecter le droit
international et notamment le droit
international humanitaire le respect du
droit et le devoir des démocrati à
l'heure où le hzbollah Libanais et
l'Iran menacent d'ouvrir un second front
au nord de l'État hébreu nous devons
tout mettre en œuvre en faveur d'une
désescalade de la violence au proches
Orient c'est également dans ce but que
le Président de la République est
présent en Israël la situation
géopolitique actuelle du Proche Orient
ne se limite pas au seul territoire
palestinien et israélien sur lequel le
monde entier a les yeux rivés l'Iran a
menacé Israël de mener une action
préventive à son encontre des menaces
ont été proférées à l'encontre de
soldats américains ce contexte nous
laisse craindre la multiplication des
foyers de conflits et de guerres dans
tout le proche or Orient et même au-delà
il faut éviter un embrasement général
madame la Première ministre vous avez
dit dans cette hémicycle que la France
est un artisan de la paix comme vous et
avec vous nous sommes convaincu que la
France tient un rôle important au côté
de ses alliés pour mettre fin à ce
conflit les déclarations du président de
la République ce jour en témoigne comme
l'a déclaré notre ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères lors de la
conférence ducer pour la paix samedi
dernier la seule solution viable est la
solution à deux états elle seule peut
permettre au peuple israélien et au
peuple palestinien de vivre dans un
climat de paix et de sécurité madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues nous
devons aujourd'hui nous unir derrière la
bannière commune de la paix nous devons
rappeler au monde entier que le seul
combat qui doit être mené est celui pour
la paix comme le disait le président de
la République raymondcré la paix est une
création continue continuons donc d'en
être l'artisan je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
la Présidente Cécile
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et
écologistes madame la Présidente vous
avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues rien ne justifie l'horreur du
samedi 7 octobre 2023 à l'heure où le
soleil se lève la barbarie s'est
exprimée sur Israël
une barbarie qui est le fruit de la
volonté du Hamas se revendiqueant
lui-même de ses actes terroristes
islamiques des morts des blessés des
otages ils étaient des enfants des
femmes des hommes qui demandaient qu'à
vivre ils ont été sauvagement exécutés
violentés blessis blessé meurtri à
jamais pris en otage ce octobre était
pourtant celui de Simat Tor
littéralement joie de la torora pour
longtemps le bruit des actes terroristes
ont fait taire le son de la joie les
revendications du Hamas sont clairs tuer
du Juif nous renvoyant un antisémisme
assumé
multiséculaire au Proche Orient comme
partout dans le monde la douleur du
peuple israélien est profonde et nous
nous y
associons depuis ce samedi 7 octobre
l'engrenage à la violence s'amplifie
heure par heure nous ne pouvons accepter
que l'État d'Israël que le gouvernement
de Monsieur netaniaahou passe du droit à
se défendre à un droit de se venger et
je fais mien ici les mots de Dominique
de Villepin qui affirmé il y a bientôt
15 jours le droit à la légitime défense
n'est pas un droit à une vengeance
indiscriminée un mort est un mort quel
que soit son ethnie sa croyance nous
nous refuserons toujours à les trier à
les
opposer la situation de Gaza n'est ni
acceptable ni soutenable déplacement
d'un million de population tir de
missile quasi en continu faisant jour
après jour des centaines de morts
supplémentaires cette situation n'est ni
acceptable ni soutenable pour le peuple
Gazaoui qui est aujourd'hui privé des
biens humains
indispensables ce sont 2 millions de
personnes qui sont privé d'eau potable
obligeant une partie d'entre elles à
boire de l'eau de mer nocive à leur
santé à cela s'ajoute un manque de
nourriture de carburant
d'électricité toutes les organisations
le disent ce sont plusieurs centaines de
camions quotidiens qui sont
indispensables pour assurer la survie
aux 2 millions d'habitants loin des 20
camions d'aide humanitaire autorisé à
circuler actuellement cette situation
n'est ni acceptable ni soutenable pour
le peuple israélien lui-même car
l'appauvrissement la survie imposée aux
habitants et nous le savons toutes et
tous un des Teros des organisations
terroristes islamiques et de la
radicalisation à venir d'une partie de
la population enfin cette situation
n'est ni acceptable ni soutenable
internationalement car se joue en ce
moment l'avenir pour plusieurs décennies
de la sécurité au proche- Orient et dans
le monde oui nous devons combattre la
guerre qui se déroule sous nos yeux la
France doit faire entendre sa voix
diplomatique et elle doit surtout jouer
un rôle indispensable pour cesser cette
guerre il n'y a pas de oui mais comme
nous l'entendons depuis plusieurs jours
il y a le respect du droit international
le respect des différentes résolution de
l'ONU qui à soit je le redis la création
de deux États mais aussi la fin de
l'occupation et de la colonisation ce
respect est une condition fondamentale à
la paix de cette volonté de paix
incarnée en
1984 par le prix Nobel de la Paix remis
conjointement à Yasser Arafat Shimon
Perez et itsac Rabine ce dernier le paya
de sa vie l'année suivante exécuté par
l'extrême droite israélienne qui ne
voulait pas de la paix alors oui
aujourd'hui des actes forts doivent être
pris par la France nous saluons le
déplacement du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron en Israël et
en sisjordanie car si le met sépare le
ha nous rassemble cependant madame la
ministre nous sommes surpris des propos
du président de ce jour pouvant laisser
entendre un nouvel engagement militaire
de la France dans le cadre d'une
extension du champ d'intervention de la
coalition internationale contre daesh si
cela devait se confirmer
inévitablement un débat et un vote au
Parlement serait indispensable au-delà
de ces propos et de ce déplacement il
nous faut aller plus loin la France doit
être à l'initiative d'une nouvelle
résolution à l'ONU qui porte l'exigence
du cesser le feu et le respect des
résolutions précédentes la France doit
pouvoir redire à l'état israélien que
que la libération de Marwan bargouti est
nécessaire car il est aujourd'hui
reconnu par beaucoup en Israël comme en
Palestine comme un de ceux qui peuvent
être un homme de dialogue entre
palestinien et Israéliens enfin et
surtout la France doit au-delà des mots
réellement s'attaquer au Hamas je le
redis le Hamas ne peut pas être pour les
progressiste que nous sommes l'avenir du
peuple palestinien la barbarie du 7
octobre dernier le démontre aux yeux du
monde entier ses liens avec le djihad
islamiste et d'autres le placent
factuellement dans le camp des ennemis
de la liberté ces dernières années peu
nombreuses étaient les voies pour
dénoncer ses agissements pour renforcer
le contrôle de l'utilisation des aides
internationales et européennes à
destination du peuple palestinien et
c'est dans un silence assourdissant que
le Hamas a assis sa domination sur Gaza
ces dernières années affaiblissant par
la même le poids de l'Autorité
palestinienne alors soyons ferm tout
point et
reconnaissons-le ce n'est pas la
destruction de Gaza qui affaiblira le
Hamas ses premiers dirigeants sont
actuellement au Qatar et si nous voulons
réellement agir cessons nos relations
diplomatiques invitons les autres pays à
le
faire pour réellement s'attaquer à cette
organisation qui a plongé comme je le
disais le monde dans un temps que nous
pensons révolue oui les auteurs comme
les instigateurs de ces attentats
devront être traduits devant les
juridictions internationale et jugé par
celle-ci je veux pour finir madame la
Première ministre redire que nous
demandons avec force et détermination un
cess lefeu immédiat le CESS le feu que
nous exigeons et pour lequel nous vous
demandons madame la Première ministre
d'agir n'est pas le maintien de la
situation actuelle il doit mettre fin au
massacre civil il doit permettre la
libération de tous les otages il doit
permettre de construire la sécurité
indispensable à tous les peuples du
Proche Orient nous savons tous ici que
sans cesser le feu immédiat c'est
malheureusement et très certainement
l'embrasement de tout le Proche Orient
qui se prépare personne ne domine la
guerre et personne ne sait au profit de
qui elle se termine madame la première
min la France n'est pas seule elle est
attendue par de nombreux habitants
d'Israël et de Palestine qui veulent
simplement mais légitimement vivre en
paix pouvoir sortir écouter de la
musique voir grandir leurs enfants je
veux saluer ici ces habitants de highfi
de Nazareth et d'ailleurs qui se
regroupe au-delà de leurs origines pour
assurer que leurs villees leur
territoire ne sombre pas dans des
affrontements entre communautés qui
seraient mortifères pour leurs habitants
depuis cette tribune du Sénat de la
République française je veux enfin dire
aux enfants d'Israël et de Palestine que
nous ne les oublions pas nous serons
toujours dans le camp de ceux qui
veulent agir pour leur permettre de
vivre grandir heureux et ainsi voir
chaque jour le soleil se lever Jean
jores affirma avec force l'affirmation
de la paix et le plus grand des combats
je souhaite avec mon groupe qu'il
devienne le combat de nous tous merci
madame la
Présidente la parole
est au président Claude maluré pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre messieurs les
ministres je ne peux commencer cette
intervention sans condamner comme tous
ceux qui m'ont précédé l'effroyable
massacre perpétré par le Hamas le 7
octobre
dernier sans dénoncer aussi ce qui chez
nous refuse de le
condamner sans exprimer notre compassion
et notre solidarité envers ses victimes
et sans avoir une pensée
particulière pour nos compatriotes
assassinés et pour ceux retenus
aujourd'hui en
otage mais quelle que soit notre colère
et quelle que soit notre
douleur nous avons un devoir le devoir
de comprendre pour
agir il y aura un avant et un après le 7
octobre
2023 comme il y a eu un avant et un
après le 11 septembre 2001 et un avant
et un après le 24 février 2022 touche
par touche le visage du monde actuel se
dessine le 20e siècle a vu la lutte à
mort des démocraties contre les
totalitarismes que nous avions on cru
avoir gagné à jamais le jour de la chute
du mur de Berlin le 11 septembre 2001 a
révélé comme un coup de tonner que les
démocraties même la plus puissante
étaient vulnérables le 24 février 2022 a
vu se reformer l'international des
dictateurs contre le monde libre Russie
Chine Corée du Nord Iran allié dans la
guerre contre l'Ukraine contre l'Europe
et l'ordre du monde libéral le 7 octobre
2023 a vu les mêmes quatre a vu les
mêmes quatre cavaliers de l'Apocalypse
des dictatures solidaires dans le refus
de dénoncer le terrorisme islamiste il a
vu aussi le reste du monde ne plus
choisir son camp comme au siècle
précédent mais se déterminer au gré de
ses intérêts le monde bipolaire du 20e
siècle a vécu le monde unipolaire des 30
derniersres années aussi celui
d'aujourd'hui voit le retour de
l'affrontement des démocraties et des
dictatures mais dans un univers
multipolaire où rien n'est joué d'avance
et dans ce monde nouveau il ne faut pas
se le cacher les démocraties ont perdu
beaucoup de terrain en 30
ans mais la partie est loin d'être jouée
et il faut d'abord tordre le coup à une
propagande mensongère qui fait floresse
grâce à la simplicité de son slogan et à
la sous-intelligentia des pseudoexerts
le sud global n'existe pas loin d'être
global ce soi-disant Sud est
parfaitement divisé une dizaine de pays
africains d'Amérique latine et surtout
l'Inde un 6e de l'humanité à elle seule
ont partagé les condamnation des
Occidentaux contre le Hamas beaucoup
d'autres n'ont pas pris position parce
qu'ils pensent que entre guillemets ce
n'est pas leur guerre ou parce qu'ils
craignent la fin de la sécurité de leur
approvisionnement pétrolier ce Sud
global allié au dictateur c'est le rêve
de l'International des tyrans comme le
mouvement des Non Alignés était la
marionnette de l'URSS mais aujourd'hui
qu'un rêve notre responsabilité
historique et de faire en sorte qu'il ne
devienne pas réalité parce qu'alors le
21e siècle se transformerait en
cauchemar on peut disserter sans fin des
réseaux qui ont poussé le Hamas à cet
effroyable massacre elles sont
nombreuses mais il en est une qui domine
toutes les autres anéantir les accords
d'Abraham et si les mains qui ont égorgé
les enfants israéliens viennent de Gaza
le cerveau qui a conçu ce plan atroce et
kavelque est
attéérant la première des réactions à
l'étranger et il faut l'en créditer a
été celle de Joe Biden qui n'a pas
hésité à traverser deux fois
l'Atlantique en 24 Hees pour
s'entretenir en tête à-tête avec ses
alliés israéliens et tenter sans succès
pour l'heure de rencontrer les
dirigeants arabes
modérés seul quelques phrases en langue
de bois ont fait l'objet d'un communiqué
de sa rencontre avec le Premier ministre
israélien mais il n''est pas besoin
d'être spécialiste de géopolitique pour
savoir ce qu'a vraiment dit le président
des États-Unis le 11 septembre 2001 a
été pour le peuple américain le même
choc que le 7 octobre pour le peuple
israélien la colère et la soif de
vengeance nous ont conduit à deux
erreurs majeures l'invasion de
l'Afghanistan dont nous sommes repartis
20 ans plus tard aussi humiliés qu'au
Vietnam et l'invasion de l'Irak qui a
embrasé tout le Moyen-Orient et qui a eu
comme conséquence le pire qui pouvait
arriver la création de daesh c'est
exacte ce que souhaitait Ben Laden nous
continuerons inlassablement de vous
aider à assurer l'existence et la
sécurité d'Israël mais ne commettez pas
la même erreur ce conseil au lendemant
même des attentats abominables du Hamas
qui ne peuvent conduire qu'à un désir de
vengeance indiscriminé était sans doute
l'un des plus difficiles que Joe Biden a
donné sa vie et les Alliés indéfectibles
d'Israël que sont les Américains étaient
sans doute les mieux placés pour le
donner mais c'est aussi le seul conseil
qui puisse se permettre demain de faire
échouer le plan du Hamas et de l'Iran en
tentant de sauver les accords d'Abraham
les Européens l'ont relayé et c'est
aujourd'hui le président français qui
délivrera le même
message la nature de l'aripost de Saal
montrera si ces conseils ont porté leur
fruit et si Israël parviendra à
distinguer la population palestinienne
des terroristes qui la prennent en otage
depuis 20 ans et dans ce monde où seul
les images comptent a montré au monde
qu'il le fait ce sera effroyablement
difficile ne parlons même pas de la
situation des otages du risque de guerre
au nord avec le hzbollah et pire avec
l'Iran il faudra résoudre ensuite une
question essentielle quelles sont les
options à moyen terme aucune ne semble
pour l'heur crédiible l'occupation est
impossible dans la durée le maintien du
Hamas au pouvoir est inacceptable le
remplacer par son rival le fata est
intenable une force d'interposition
arabe est inenvisageable et un
gouvernement fantoche est
inimaginable une guerre totale contre le
peuple palestinien et pas uniquement
contre le Hamas outre qu'elle serait
contraire au droits humanitair ruinerait
la détente amorcée par les accords
d'Abraham avec ses voisins Bahrain les
Émirats barabunis le Maroc et
potentiellement l'Arabie Saoudite cette
détente est le seul espoir d'un
Moyen-Orient apaisé et concentré sur son
développement économique plutôt que sur
l'affrontement des idéologies et des
guerres de religion elle vient de subir
un coup terrible et l'échec du sommet
pour la paix entre arabe et européens
qui vient d'avoir lieu au Ker n'incite
pas à l'optimisme à long terme la seule
façon d'éradiquer le terrorisme
islamiste est pour Israël et ses
partenaires arabes de trouver le chemin
de la stabilité et un jour de la paix
parvenir à une CO ance pacifiée avec ses
voisins n'est pas un choix pour Israël
mais une obligation ceci suppose de
résoudre enfin le problème non résolu
depuis toutes ces années comment réussir
la cohabitation de deux peuples qui
vivent sur cette même partie du monde et
qui y resteront les accords d'Abraham
avaient commencé d'apporter une pierre à
cet édifice de paix la prise en compte
de l'avenir des palestinien qui
constitue la tâche aveugle de ces
accords doit les compléter Sion veut que
le Moyen-Orient ne reparte pas pour 20
ou 30 ans de guerre identique aux 75 ans
qui se sont écoulés depuis
1947 les massacres du 7 octobre semblent
nous éloigner pour longtemps d'une telle
réponse mais l'histoire est faite de
surprises et le vertige d'un nouvel
embrasement dont les conséquences
seraient dramatiques peut peut-être
faire retrouver le chemin de la raison
c'est à cette très fragile espérance que
notre pays doit s'emplayer je vous
remercie
monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame m la première ministre le 7
octobre dernier le Hamas a frappé Israël
et son peuple avec une violence abjecte
lors de cette attentat terroriste plus
de 1400 personnes ont été massacrées
plus de 3000 ont été blessé avec une
barbarie qui a choqué les esprits et
révulser les cœurs aux quatre coins du
monde aux quatre coins du monde nous
pleurons les victimes israéliennes mais
aussi plus de 100 personnes représentant
38 nationalités dont une trentaine de
nos compatriotes nous déplorons aussi
plus de sans otage dont nous appelons à
la libération
immédiate qu'il me soit permis de
réitérer à cette tribune notre
condamnation la plus ferme de ces
atrocités notre soutien plein et entier
au peuple d'Israël et à ses amis à
travers le monde le 7 octobre 2023 est
déjà entré dans les livres d'histoire
l'une de ces dates charnières que les
élèves apprendront par cœur comme le
jour où l'engrenage s'est enclenché et
le piège du Hamas s'est refermé à
l'horreur de la barbarie du Hamas a
succédé la violente ripos du
gouvernement israélien qui prend la
forme d'une punition collective opérant
un siège destructeur et illégal de la
bande de Gaza noyé sous un tapis de
bombe qui tue indistinctement
combattants et civils toute précaution
prise il ne fait pas de doute que les
victimes civiles se comptent par
milliers dont dont de nombreux enfants
notre solidarité s'étend naturellement
au peuple palestinien et à toutes ses
vies fauchées le le droit à la sécurité
d'Israël auquel nous sommes profondément
attachés ne peut exister que dans le
respect du droit international
humanitaire ce n'est pas un droit à une
vengeance aussi aveugle que
contre-productive si la brève histoire
du 21e siècle nous a appris quelque
chose c'est que ne gagne pas les guerres
contre la terreur quand pour se prémunir
ou se venger du terrorisme les démocrati
se rendent coupable de crimes de guerre
et de massacre de civils elles ne font
que renforcer ce qu'ell cherche à
anéantir le terrorisme se nourrit du
désespoir et de la haine s'il est
possible de tuer les combattants du
Hamas il n'est pas possible de tuer une
idéologie le combat contre une idéologie
ne peut-être que politique
malheureusement et c'était l'objectif de
l'agresseur c'est la perspective de
résolution politique du conflit qui a
reculé la haine et le ressentiment sont
à leur paroxisme agités de chaque côté
par les partisans de l'anentissement de
l'adversaire qu'il s'appelle Hamas ou
extrême droite messianique ces
pourvoyeurs de haine vitupérant masquent
la réalité structurelle qui n'est certe
pas la réalité de l'instant l'immense
majorité des Palestiniens et des
Israéliens aspire à vivre en paix alors
que tsal prépare une intervention
terrestre dans la bande de Gaza la
perspective de paix ne Seigne pas
seulement entre Israël et la Palestine
mais pour toute la région voire au-delà
au nord d'Israël les échanges de tir se
multip entre le hzbollah et Saal
entraînant ce weekend les premières
menaces à peine voilées de l'Iran
menaces auxquelles la diplomatie
américaine a immédiatement répondu entre
stratégie de dissuasion et perspective
d'un conflit généralisé le le monde vit
dans l'expectative plus que jamais il
est temps de stopper cet engrenage de
violence mortifère qui ne peut
qu'affaiblir davantage nos démocratie
fragile face aux empires autoritaires
ces derniers observent avec intérêt la
dégradation du climat international pour
mener à bien leur propre véléité
expansionniste à commencé par la
tentative à l'œuvre de conquête de
l'Ukraine en conséquence nous demandons
un cesser le feu immédiat et l'arrêt des
combats ces crimes de guerre doivent
cesser une intervention militaire au sol
de tsal dont les objectifs et
l'efficacité sont plus qu'incertains
serait dramatique et extrêmement
coûteuse en vie humaine qu'il s'agisse
de soldats et réservistes israéliens ou
de civils palestiniens
il est également indispensable de
massifier l'intervention humanitaire
dans la bande de Gaza l'ONU estime le
besoin à plus de 100 camions par jour
nous en sommes très loin madame la
Première ministre si nous avons entendu
une inflexion bienvenue de votre
discours évoquant une trêve humanitaire
le propos du président de la République
ce midi à Tel Aviv nous inquiète
grandement que signifie pour
l'exécutif faire participer la
coopération internationale de lutte
contre daesh à la lutte contre le Hamas
s'il s'agit de participer à des
bombardements de la bande de Gaza c'est
parfaitement inacceptable s'il s'agit de
livrer des armes ça allait tout autant
rappelons que les bombardements contre
daesh ont fait entre 1300 sources
officielles et 12000 sources
journalistiques victimes civiles dans
des territoires infiniment moins denses
que la bande de Gaza loin de telle véité
béliqueuse la France doit retrouver la
voie forte qui était celle de Jacques
Chirac la voix qui n'hésitait pas à
refuser d'engager nos armées dans une
inutile guerre contre la terreur en Irak
la voix qui était salué en Palestine
comme partout dans le monde arabe il est
indispensable que la France fasse de
nouveau entendre cette voix et la face
raisonnée dans toute l'Europe depuis
trop d'années l'Europe a fait sien
s'agissant du conflit
israelllo-palestinien le vieux principe
d'Henry cuil il n'y a pas de problème
qu'une absence de solution ne finisse
par résoudre
symbole s'il en est de l'âcheté
politique ce principe de cuœil porte
pourtant une signification trop souvent
oubliée l'absence de solution provoquera
la solution simpliste du problème dans
la douleur ou la violence il est
déporable que nous en arrivions là
depuis trop d'années nous avons laissé
prospérer le Hamas sur les ruines du
processus de paix anéanti par
l'assassinat d'Isaac Rabine et sur les
ruines de l'Autorité palestinienne
dévitalisée et démonétisée par le zure
du pouvoir la corruption mais surtout
l'absence de toute perspective politique
or sans perspective politique le choix
du peuple palestinien se résume au
suicide à petit feu ou à l'explosion de
violence je n'ai pas le temps de
reprendre le cours d'une histoire
tumultueuse et complexe de plus de 7
décennies mais nous faisons nôre le
propos et la démonstration magistrale
effectué hier à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale par notre collègue
Jean-Louis bourlange président de la
commission des affaires étrangères il a
tracé le chemin qui pourrait permettre
loin des polémiques à la classe
politique de parler d'une seule voix il
a rappelé que le préalable à tout
processus de paix était l'arrêt et le
reflux de la colonisation illégale qui
depuis deux décennies gettoise et
démantelle la sjordanie dans son annonce
de reprise du processus de paix le
président de la République semble
partager ce constat nous le saluons mais
chat et Chaudé cint l'eau froide nous
nous méfions des grands discours
rarement suivis des faits de notre chef
de l'État aux promesses doivent succéder
sans tarder les actes aussi nous
demandons au président de la République
de reconnaître l'état palestinien comme
l'ont déjà fait 138 pays dans le monde
pour construire la paix demain il faudra
un interlocuteur nous souhaitons que la
France pèse de tout son poids pour
organiser une transition démocratique à
la tête de l'Autorité palestinienne pour
ce faire il conviendrait de plaider pour
la libération des prisonniers politiques
palestinien notamment ceux à même
d'incarner cette transition et notre
pensée partagée AC avec Dominique de
Villepin va en premier lieu vers Marwan
bargouti si Israël et la communauté
internationale sont incapables
d'accompagner une telle transition
démocratique alors c'est toute la
sisjordanie qui menace de plonger dans
le chaos à la mort de Mahmoud Abbas
occultant tout espoir de paix il est
encore temps d'agir avec force en jouant
une partition différente de celle des
États-Unis par son existence même
l'Union européenne est la preuve par
l'exemple que les ennemis irréductibles
d'hier peent devenir les alliés de
demain l'Union doit jouer un rôle
d'arbitre pour construire la paix
condition sineéquanon de la sécurité
d'Israël et pour que cesse ce conflit
qui depuis tr/4 de siècle a engendré
tant de souffrance tant d'humiliation et
emporté tant de vie il est encore temps
d'agir pour la paix une juste cause qui
finira par triompher comme le disait
isaacabine merci merci monsieur le
Président Gard la parole est à madame la
Présidente maris scarer pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 8 minutes madame la
présidente madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le 4 mars 82 le président
François mitteran s'exprima ainsi à
l'acné 7 je ne sais pas s'il y a une
réponse acceptable au problème
palestinien mais nul mais nul doute
qu'il n'y a un problème et que non
résolu il pèsera d'un poids tragique et
durable sur cette région du monde qu
décennies plus tard le 7 octobre dernier
Israël a été confronté à ce lourd poids
de la stratégie de la tragédie pardon
les Israéliens ont vécu un drame absolu
l'assassinat aveugle de plus de 1300
personnes par le Hamas essentiellement
des civils dont certains bationaux et
l'enlèvement de près de 200 hommes
femmes et enfants vivants dans le sud
d'Israël les conditions de ce massacre
ont profondément choqué ils ont sidéré
comme j'ai pu le dire dans cet hémicycle
le 11 octobre dernier de telles
atrocités ne laissent pas de place à la
nuance ou à la polémique une nouvelle
fois le groupe RDSE condamne sans
réserve ces attaques terroristes et nous
avons une pensée pour toutes les
victimes et nous pensons également aux
familles françaises touché par cette
tragédie neuf de nos compatriotes
figurent parmi les otages tout doit être
mise en œuvre pour les
libérer rien ne peut justifier unel un
tel acharnement sur des civils une fois
de plus le terrorisme islamique a montré
qu'il était sans égard pour la vie
humaine des attentats de septembre 2001
aux États-Unis à ceux de novembre 2015 à
Paris on pensait avoir vu le pire et
bien non hélas malheureusement aussi
comme on pouvait s'y attendre ce drame
du 7 octobre a conduit à un autre drame
celui que vit en ce moment la population
palestinienne prise sous le feu du tsal
dans une dans un Gaza assiégé deux
peuples souffrent aujourd'hui Israël a
riposté pour défendre ses concitoyens
comment pouvait-il en être autrement au
regard de tous ces meurtres impensables
comment ne pas comprendre que ce pays
défende tout simplement son droit à la
sécurité un droit d'autant plus légitime
que les actes du Hamas ont porté le
germe du génocide renvoyant la
population juive à un passé
particulièrement douloureux mais cela
est vrai aussi le résultat de cet
enchaînement c'est que la souffrance des
Israéliens entraîne la souffrance des
Palestiniens la douleur n'a ni frontière
tombé dans l'abîme de l'obscurantisme à
Gaza cela a été rappelé on compterait
plus de 4000 morts des centaines de
milliers de personnes déplacées et une
situation humanitaire catastrophique si
l'on interroge parfois sur les buts de
la guerre dans un conflit l'objectif du
Hamas était clair semer une discorde IR
conciliable entre Palestiniens et
Israéliens pour mieux en tirer les
bénéfices à Gaza et même au-delà comme
on le voit tristement dans certaines
régions du monde où le Hamas sert
desétendards d'une fierté retrouvée nous
le savons les têtes pensantes du Hamas
des autocrates souvent confortablement
installés hors de Gaza avec la
complaisance de certains états veulent
cette escalade parce que le Hamas est
l'ennemi de la paix parce que le Hamas
est l'ennemi du peuple palestinien parce
que le Hamas parie sur la stratégie du
chaos la communauté internationale doit
trouver les moyens de sortir de ce piège
il faut s'en convaincre et convaincre à
terme la solution n'est certainement pas
militre et convaincre à terme la
solution n'est certainement pas
militaire on le voit bien la position
d'équilibre est difficile à trouver
entre le droit d'Israël à se défendre et
le respect du droit international en
particulier le respect du droit
international humanitaire le droit de la
guerre c'est une sorte d'oxyort la
réalité de la guerre est bien trop
brutale et reste rarement dans les
règles la communauté internationale
va-t-elle le supporter longtemps alors
que les États-Unis sont un allié
inconditionnel d'Israël nous avons tous
bien entendu le président du message
américain en direction du gouvernement
de benyami
netanahou lui disant ne faites pas les
mêmes erreurs que nous après le 11 sept
ne soyez pas consumé par la rage c'est
bien évidemment difficile à entendre
pour une opinion publique israélienne
traumatisée pourtant la diplomatie doit
rapidement reprendre le dessus car le
risque d'un embrasement régional plane
derrière ce conflit du Hamas au
eszbollah il n'y a qu'un pas et du
hzbollah à théran le chemin est court
aussi je salue les efforts de la France
qui est sur tous les fronts au sein de
la communauté internationale et qui
dialogue avec plusieurs pays de la
région vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Première ministre préserver autant que
possible la population civile
palestinienne doit être aussi une
priorité le principe d'une trêve
humanitaire que vous demandez est
naturellement conformme aux valeurs
humanistes que la que la France défend
l'eau la nourriture les médicaments
doivent rentrer à Gaza pour la survie
des victimes du conflit il s'agit aussi
de redonner du sens au droits
humanitaires que j'ai voqu à l'instant
sur le front politique la solution à
deux états refait surface c'est une
bonne chose les accords d'Abraham ont
paru suffire à garantir une sécurité
relative à Israël le Premier ministre
netanahou s'est sans doute bercé
d'illusion avec ses relations de bon
voisinage tout comme il a pensé que
l'affaiblissement de l'Autorité
palestinienne n'était pas si mal le
président de la République entend
défendre cette option qui regagne du
terrain il faut en effet rapidement
combler le vide diplomatique qui s'était
installé autour du conflit
israélo-palestinien de leur côté les
Palestiniens doivent absolument
restaurer sur leur territoire une
autorité politique claire avec la lutte
contre le terrorisme mon groupe partage
cette orientation car ni la terreur ni
la vengeance n'apporteront la paix à
l'évidence ce ne sera pas facile le
sommet pour la paix qui vient tout juste
de se tenir en Égypte le démontre
l'heure n'est pas tout à fait à la
convergence tant l'épée de damoclè d'un
assaut israélien dans Gaza pèse lourd
enfin parce que le conflit ce conflit
trouve un écho au-delà du Proche-Orient
notre responsabilité en tant qu'élu et
en tant que républicain et de ne pas
faire de la Palestine un enjeu de
solidarité sur notre territoire afin de
ne pas accentuer des fractures déjà
palpables nous devons tenir dans notre
pays un langage de vérité en particulier
auprès des jeunes pour qu'ils gardent la
distance nécessaire et qu' ne décrypte
pas le monde dans lequel ils vivent au
travers du prisme culturel ou religieux
d'une façon générale ne baissons pas les
bras face à l'obscurantisme où qu'il se
trouve madame la Première ministre nous
serons à vos côtés pour soutenir toutes
les initiative de la France pour la paix
et la
démocratie en 1919 Clémenceau dans son
discours à Verdun soulignait qu'il était
bien plus dur de faire la paix que de
faire la guerre malgré toutes les embûes
la paix doit toujours rester la première
boussole des peuples gardons ainsi à
l'esprit les mots de
saintexupéri qui disait pour ce qui est
de la venir il ne s'agit pas de le
prévoir mais de le rendre possible je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Marie SCER la parole est à
Monsieur Emeric Durox pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe pour 3
minutes chers
collègues madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues à l'heure où tous les regards
du monde se porte encore une fois sur la
poudrière du Proche Orient dans
l'attente anxieuse de sa probable
explosion permettez-moi d'avoir une
pensée émue pour toutes les victim de ce
conflit et en particulier pour nos 30
compatriotes assassinés par les
terroristes du Hamas et les neuf
Français encore portés disparus que nous
espérons toujours vivant car oui le
Hamas c'est bien une organisation
terroriste parmi les plus horribles et
certains avaient encore un doute les
macabres découvertes de leurs svic et de
leurs crimes les plus abjects depuis le
7 octobre n'en laissent plus aucun aux
hommes et aux femmes de bonne volonté
seul d'indigne calcul électoraux et
d'infames idéologies pourrai inciter des
politiques irresponsables à qualifier
les actes du Hamas ou cette organisation
de résistance souillant ainsi ce beau
mot pour lequel tant de français sont
morts face à cette barbarie Israël seule
vraie démocratie du Proche Orient a le
droit et même le devoir de défendre sa
population dans le respect bien sûr du
droit international dans ce contexte
extrêmement tendu et animé de mauvaise
passion l'on aurait pu espérer une voix
française forte au-dessus de la mêlée
hélas trois fois hélas cette voix
française est portée depuis plus de 6
ans par un homme qui avait déclaré avant
d'accéder aux plus hautes fonctions
qu'il n'y avait pas de culture française
comment finalement lui reprocher de ne
pas comprendre ce qui fait sa
singularité ce qui fait que cette voix
française était autrefois attendue
écoutée et respectée parmi
dans le monde entier et notamment au
Proche-Orient où l'histoire nous avait
donné une place particulière loin de
saisir l'enjeu crucial du moment le
président de la République a préféré le
lendemain des carnages du 7 octobre se
rendre en Allemagne pour un séminaire
intergouvernemental puis en Albanie dont
il veut apparemment faire un nouveau
membre de l'UE contre toute logique et
contre toutes les opinions publiques il
aura fallu attendre 17 jours pour qu'il
atterrisse en fin en Israël bien après
tous les autres dirigeants européens
mais pour y dire quoi puisque notre
singularité n'est plus que dira le
président de la République que naura dit
un Olaf Scholz ou même uneur van
derleyen qui se prend apparemment pour
une chef d'État pour que la France porte
que sa voix porte à nouveau il faut
retrouver notre tradition diplomatique
allié mais non alignée forte car libre
et constante dans le temps c'est tout
l'objectif de la Déclaration des droits
des peuples et des nations que Marine Le
Pen a présenté il y a quelques semaines
les grands principes énoncé dans cette
charte à commencé par l'égalité en
dignité et en droit de tous les peuples
et les nations pourrait servir de guide
pour trouver demain un règlement au
conflit israëlo-palestinien prémise à la
normalisation des relations
interétatiques au Proche Orient cette
proposition pourra devenir un outil que
la France de tout temp créatrice de
droits nouveaux pourra porter dans le
monde notre pays retrouvera ainsi cette
place si particulière dans le concert
des nations que beaucoup de pays du
Proche Orient attendent à nouveau cette
place qui lui parla qui lui permet en
même temps d'assurer la sécurité des
Français de promouvoir nos intérêts
nationaux et de rester fidèles à notre
histoire tel que clémenenceau le disait
ici même à cette tribune le 11 novembre
1918 la France sera toujours le soldat
de l'idéal je vous
remercie merci chers collègues pour
répondre aux orateurs la parole est
désormais à Monsieur Olivier betch
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de l'étranger monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
souhaiterais pouvoir
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions qui ont été posées lors des
interventions des différents orateurs en
commençant peut-être par la question
relative à
l'extension au Hamas à la lutte contre
le Hamas de la coalition internationale
contre le terrorisme vous nous
interrogez pour savoir quelles sont les
formes que pourrait prendre cette
extension je rappelle simplement que la
coalition qui a été mise en place contre
daesh euh n'implique pas exclusivement
des actions militaires sur le terrain
mais également un certain nombre
d'actions à la fois en matière de
renseignement en matière de lutte contre
le financement du terrorisme ou encore
en matière de lutte contre le djihadisme
en ligne et sur les réseaux sociaux le
président de la République vient
d'ailleurs euh de déclarer que euh cette
lutte contre le terrorisme nécessite la
coopération de tous et que c'est le prix
nécessaire pour assurer la sécurité et
la paix dans la région je souhaitais
également
rassurer le président
rotillo qui nous demande une tolérance
zéro contre l'antisémitisme c'est bien
la politique du gouvernement euh la
question sur l'aide humanitaire pour
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas un €o
qui aille au
Hamas notre aide humanitaire passe
évidemment par les agences de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies
notamment l'unvra et le PAM ainsi que
par le CICR et différentes ONG et nous
veillons tout particulièrement
évidemment à ce que pas 1 € ne termine à
destination du Hamas je remercie le
sénateur Cadic d'avoir mentionné les 30
français qui ont été assassinés par le
Hamas ainsi que les 9uf toujours disparu
et vous assure que nous déployons tous
les efforts pour qu'il soit ramené en ce
qui concerne les otages à l'affection de
leur famille je voulais également euh
rassurer euh sur la pleine implication
de notre diplomatie pour le président
Claude maluré et la présidente Marise
carer euh sur euh la question de
l'escalade nous sommes évidemment
pleinement molisés pour éviter tout
escalade euh dans la région et
particulièrement également euh pour la
préservation des accords Abraham qui est
une priorité également de notre
diplomatie enfin euh si la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
n'est pas ici au banc ce soir c'est
parce qu'elle est elle-même au Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies pleinement
impliqué où nous demandons maintenant
depuis plus d'une semaine euh une trêve
humanitaire avec à terme un cess le feu
qui est une condition évidemment à ce
qu'on puisse reprendre les négociations
politiques pour assurer cette solution à
deux états mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour conclure
ce débat je vais donner la parole à
madame la Première ministre Madame
Élisabeth
borne merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
alors que ce débat touche à sa fin je
souhaite remercier les oratrices et
orateurs de tous les groupes
politiques vous l'avez tous dit la
situation est grave elle exigeait un
débat respectueux un débat à la hauteur
des
circonstances cela a été le cas et je
tiens à le saluer nos parcours nos idées
donc nos visions ne sont pas les mêmes
nos sensibilités peuvent parfois
différer c'est la démocratie mais
au-delà de ces divergences nos points de
vues se rejoignent sur plusieurs points
essentiels c'est important
particulièrement dans de telles
circonstances premièrement je constate
un large consensus pour condamner s
ambiguité l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
sur
Israël un consensus pour nommer
l'agression barbare dont a été victime
ce pays pour dénoncer l'horreur et la
tragédie que constituent ces attentats
les mots ont un sens refuser d'en
prononcer certains en a également un ici
au Sénat personne n'a d'État d'â pour
qualifier le Hamas de groupe terroriste
et je veux le saluer et collectivement
nous reconnaissons à Isra
le droit d'assurer sa défense dans le
respect du droit
international le deuxième point qui nous
rassemble largement c'est la volonté de
protéger les civils et l'attention pour
les populations de
Gaza nous nous accordons pour affirmer
que les populations palestiniennes sont
également les victimes du Hamas nous
nous accordons pour dénoncer la
catastrophe humanitaire en cours à Gaza
et la mort de milliers de civils
palestiniens il n'y a pas de double
standard face aux victimes nous les
pleurons toutes pas de double standard
face aux civils tous doivent être
protégés la position de la France est
claire et je l'ai réaffirmé devant vous
nous appelons à des trêves humanitaires
qui pourront mener à un cesser le feu et
à l'accès immédiat et sécurisé de l'aide
vers
Gaza enfin je note un troème point
d'accord c'est notre recherche de la
paix
durable comme vous je je crois que nous
devons tout faire pour éviter un
embrasement régional et comme je l'ai
dit en introduction je suis convaincu
que par notre histoire notre voie
indépendante la France a un rôle à jouer
à court terme comme de manière plus
durable pour bâtir la paix et une
solution politique à ce conflit c'est
précisément dans cette optique que le
Président de la République est dans la
région aujourd'hui tout faire pour
éviter l'escalade et créer les
conditions d'une reprise du processus
politique pour une solution à deux états
et comme le président de la République
vient de le déclarer après son entretien
avec le président Mahmoud Abbas nous
sommes convaincus qu'une initiative
forte pour la paix et la sécurité doit
être conduite la quête légitime de
sécurité est une illusion tant qu'une
paix juste n'est pas
établie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs si notre débat portait sur la
situation au Proche Orient vous avez
exprimé au cours de vos interventions
des inquiétudes sur l'impact de ce
conflit dans notre pays ces inquiétudes
nous les entendons nous y répondons avec
le président de la République et tout le
gouvernement nous continuons à combattre
inlassablement l'antisémitisme sous
toutes ses
formes l'antisémitisme est un poison et
comme toutes les haines il n'a pas sa
place dans notre République dans ce
combat notre détermination est totale
dès l'attaque contre contre Israël avec
le président de la République nous avons
demandé au ministre de l'Intérieur
d'adresser un message de vigilance au
préfet et aux forces de l'ordre nous
avons aussi réhaussé la protection des
lieux sensibles en particulier les
écoles et les lieux de culte grâce
notamment à l'opération
sentinelle comme je l'ai indiqué hier
depuis le 7 7 octobre plus de 300
personnes ont été arrêtées pour des
actes ou des menaces m nous avons aussi
reçu plus de 4000 alertes via la
plateforme Faros pour des contenus éux
en ligne plus de 300 d'entre elles sont
désormais entre les mains de la justice
dans l'objectif d'identifier et de punir
leurs auteurs nous ne faiblirons pas
face au fléau de l'antisémitisme en
ligne comme dans la rue nous ne
laisserons rien
passer enfin je veux condamner à nouveau
l'attitude de ceux qui voudraient
utiliser ce conflit comme prétexte à
toutes les outrances toutes les dérives
notamment à des fins
électoralistes c'est irresponsable c'est
dangereux pour notre pacte
républicain je me réjouis que cette
position soit largement partagés dans
les travers du Sénat mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les
circonstances sont graves et dans ces
moments nous avons un devoir de cohésion
nationale un devoir de
responsabilité un devoir de dire les
choses et de ne pas attiser les tenstion
de notre société je sais pouvoir compter
sur le Sénat dans cet
objectif avec le gouvernement c'est
toujours la voie que nous choisirons et
avec le président de la République nous
défendront toujours le chemin de la
justice et de la paix c'est l'honneur et
la singularité de la France de rester
une nation indépendante capable de se
tenir au côté du peuple israélien comme
du peuple pales
je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h pour la suite de l'examen